welcome to the digital age where data
isn't just power it's the year we
breathe the language we speak and the
future we are building every second the
internet explodes with new content did
you know that over 4.4 million blog post
are published every day and Google
processes over 40,000 search queries
every second that's a dling amount of
information in the sever expanding
Universe of data how do we make sense of
what matters how do we filter out the
noise and find the signals enter the
world of gp4 not just anyi but a vision
equipped Super Brain that's changing the
way we interact with the vast ocean of
web data imagine a tool so Advanced it
doesn't just read text but sees and
understand images charts and even the
layout of web pages just like a human
but here's the kicker it does this at a
speed and scale that's simply out of our
leak today we will see one of those
features that is gp4 vision and before
we move on just a quick info for you
guys if you one of the aspiring python
Enthusiast or a ml Enthusiast looking
for online training and graduating from
the best universities or a professional
who elicits to switch careers in Ai and
ml by learning from the experts then try
giving a short to Simply learns
postgraduate program in a ml in
collaboration with P University and IBM
by enrolling in this certification
program you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt and
Jing chat jpd explainable AI machine
learning algorithm supervised and
unsupervised learning model training and
optimizations and there's much more on
the list with hands-on experience in
tools you will catch the eye of top
recruiters so what are you waiting for
hurry up and enroll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses you can find the course
Link in the description box and pin
comment without any further Ado let's
get started so opena recently released a
multimodel version of gp4 called gp4
Vision that is GPT 4V so GPT 4V can
understand images as input and answer
questions based on it 80% of the world's
data is unstructured and Scattered
across formats like websites PDFs or
images that are hard to access and
analyze we believe that this new era of
multimodel models will have a big impact
on the web scraping and document
processing space because it's now
possible to understand unstructured data
without having to rely on complex OCR
Technologies or tooling so let's explore
potential application of GPD 4 week for
web scripting so first what we'll do is
we will open any website or we'll just
open the simply learn website only and
we will save this as a HTML
dog HTML Only We have replaced
it so this is the HTML
log we will drag and drop it to chat jpd
and now ask the chat jity to web script
the data so we'll ask the chat jity that
use the above HTML
file
and scrip the
data from it so first we'll see the
scrip data in text format only and after
that we will uh ask the CH to scrip the
data into Json format or if there are
any CSS files or styling or metadata so
we'll ask the J gyy to do
so so you could see that jjd has
responded that the HTML file you
uploaded from the simply one website it
provides a variety of courses and the
platform aims too so it it has just
given us the summary so now we'll ask
jity to extract the data into Json
format above
HTML
file
in format so you could see that it's
analyzing
so you could see that it has extracted
the data into Json format and here's a B
for of the extracted data so this is how
you could web script the data from the
websites using GPT for vision so now
what we'll do we will go to all courses
click on explore the category so here
you could see all the courses of the
data science and business Analytics
category so what we'll do we'll ask the
chat GP what we'll do is we'll ask the
chat JP to extract the titles of all the
courses so for that first we'll save the
page as HTML
Doc and we'll upload to chat
jpd and going back to the page just
inspect so you could see that that
heading three has the title of this
course so we'll provide this as a
reference to the chat J so it can
understand and extract all the other
titles from this page so we'll get back
to chat JB and ask him that extract the
course
title from the
attached web
page or HTML do
HTML and you can use Python and
beautiful
soup and
xort
the results to a CSV
file and the title
tag
H3 like this and now we will provide
it just copy the element past it to chat
jpd extract all the PO
titles attached web page okay let's see
what does a chat shiy respond to
this so you would see that it has
created a CSF file so we'll click this
and open the
file and it has extracted all the titles
which are present in
H3 into a CSV file but we asked only for
the course
titles and it has done so for all the H3
points and now we'll ask the chat JP to
extract the
metadata into Json
format from the
attached HTML
file
so you could see that JD has provided
the metadata into Json format and
similarly we can ask it for other
scripts if this web page has any
scripts provide that to in Json
format so you could see that I extracted
the scripts from the HTML file and
presented them in Json format so here's
a preview of the extracted scripts so
this is the script that contains the
JavaScript code embedded within the web
page and due to the length of the
scripts only the first part is shown
here if you need the full Chon file all
the scripts please let me
know yeah
I need the full
script so you could see that it has
provided us the Json file so we can just
download it and open it with any
ID so this is the Json format for the
whole web
page moving back we'll move back to the
website and now we'll ask chat jpt to
extract the data from this image that is
or like make someone understand what
does this image show so first we'll do
is we'll save the page into HTML
dog and P this
image
element and ask the chat jbd first we'll
upload the HTML file and ask the chat
J uh explain the
graph present in the
attached web
page and describe it so we save and
submit it and let's see what does it
respond if it doesn't respond we'll just
get back to the web page and inspect the
element for it and provide the div class
or the particular element so it could
understand for Which diagram
asking CH to describe
it see so file you Prov it title Post in
data science C tag does not display it
content in a format that allows me to
interact with or interpret any edate
graphs so we provide
you with the
element present
HTML
file read that and
explain the
graph for Di to
us so let's
see so you could see that it has
provided the information about that
image that the HTML snipp to provid
inter appearance to represent a style
graphical element likely part of a
larger graph or visual representation
specifically it describes a div element
rotated by minus 53° containing another
div with a background color of a shade
of pink so this is how the gp4 version
works and it also describes the images
so with that we have come to the end of
this session I hope you like this
tutorial if you liked it please give it
a thumbs up like share and subscribe
till then stay safe and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here